on a promis de régler le cas de la
possession simple ça ce qu'on vient de
faire
après la légalisation du cannabis
c'était la suite logique
dès aujourd'hui il est plus facile et
surtout gratuit de demander un pardon
une nouvelle attendue au pays si grande
légal pourquoi qu'il condamnait du monde
c'est vraiment cool parce que c'est un
acte bénin y avait quand même plusieurs
embûches ans pour obtenir un pardon
depuis 2012 y avait des frais de 630 $
pour obtenir un pardon donc c'est
évidemment pas la portée de tout le
monde
selon elle le délai de traitement
pouvait atteindre 10 ans cette procédure
simplifiée devrait aider les personnes
condamnées à réintégrer la société
mais oh pardon ne leur permettra
peut-être pas d'aller aux états unis le
problème qui pourrait demeurer c'est que
si on a déjà essayé traversé la
frontière avant d'obtenir un pardon pu
cueillir des traces dans le dossier
canadien mais dans le dossier des
douaniers américains
bien évidemment le canada pas
juridiction pour effacer ses traces là
que j'ai eu d'écho justement cet été de
gens qui ont commis ce qu'on appelait
autrefois une erreur de jeunesse et qui
ne se rappelait pas du tout avoir un
dossier criminel à cause de cette seule
la france et pour qui c'est revenu à la
mémoire au moment de traverser les
lignes dans un voyage aux etats unis
ce député du npd anticipe des problèmes
pour les personnes condamnées
il aimerait qu ottawa et au delà du
simple pardon ce qu'on demande depuis le
début c'est la radiation pure et simple
du dossier lorsqu'il ce qui est proposé
c'est une suspension du casier
judiciaire ne s'est pas un effacement
c'est vraiment les données vont être
conservées mais ailleurs
autrement dit on garde des traces de
cette condamnation pour des raisons de
sécurité publique tout de même le
gouvernement s'attend recevoir au moins
dix mille demandes de pardon au cours
des prochains mois ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morrell